and if they can do this to president
trump what do you think they can do to
the rest of us we'll have full breaking
coverage all night long here now with
more fox news legal analyst greg jarrett
harvard law professor alan dershowitz is
with us greg we'll start with you
if you look at the presidential records
act which is what we're told this is all
about
i i mean i assume there's a chance that
maybe classified documents were taken to
mar-a-lago
i understood from reports that there was
a process that they were on you know
they were going through
they said they're willing to give all
those things back
um
why didn't they just say can we come
over and take a look at
what you have and make sure that there's
no classified documents here just like
why didn't they say to peter navarro
his attorney have your client report at
8 am at this location or paul manafort
or roger stone
uh why the big show only when it's a
conservative
because it's donald trump and
this is the weaponization for political
purposes by
the fbi and the department of justice
you're right sean when you identify the
presidential records act of 1968
78 which
is far
from a model of clarity and in fact it's
one of the more opaque laws you'll ever
read
one of the problems with it is
that it gives discretion
and authority to the incumbent president
to decide what constitutes presidential
papers he may identify exclude and
dispose of presidential papers and you
point out the classified nature
allegedly of some of the documents
identified by the national archives
they're not a competent agency to
recognize classified documents because a
president is the ultimate authority in
declassifying documents he may do so
with a wave of his hand without
notification to the national archive so
i think what you're really seeing here
uh is an abuse of power by the fbi and
absolutely uh both merrick garland the
attorney general and the fbi director
christopher ray
they would have to have they would have
to have signed off on this greg you
would agree with that correct oh
absolutely they signed i mean look no
agent or official at the fbi
is going to undertake a a raid of this
magnitude on a former president united
states without going to the individuals
at the very top that's garland and ray
all right let's talk about two other
cases professor dershowitz and then i'll
get your overall view on on this
particular raid that's got that went on
earlier today
james comey was accused pretty much of
something very similar if you recall if
you remember the case of sandy berger
sandy berger went into the national
archives he literally shoved documents
down into his crotch
on his in his backside into his socks
and walked out with those documents but
then everybody in the media every
democrat he was just sloppy very sloppy
as he shoved it down his pants he was
sloppy you know he didn't mean to take
them with him um and everybody
bought that excuse so this therein
brings up the double standard issue what
are your thoughts
well definitely there is a double
standard uh we've seen so many instances
of allegedly classified material being a
compromise the key point that
everybody's missing here is that donald
trump was not in mar-a-lago so there was
no reason not to issue a subpoena
returnable tomorrow
so that there's no claim that trump
could have destroyed anything this
should have been a subpoena not a search
warrant if it is a search warrant it has
to have a high level of cause
demonstrating that the evidence would
have been destroyed not only that but
under the law if you seize a safe you
don't go into the safe you have to get a
special warrant to get into the safe and
you have to prove that the material in
the locked safe
would have been destroyed so it seems to
me that they have violated the rules of
the justice department they have gone
after both a former president and a
future candidate and they darn well
better have smoking gun proof which i
don't see happening and clearly there's
been a double standard here but even if
it was a single standard it's not good
enough you don't get a warrant unless a
subpoena won't suffice in a democratic
rule of law country you do it
legitimately you go to the lawyer you
say by tomorrow i want that safe
delivered to the justice department i
want these documents turned over and
unless you can demonstrate that there
was a very substantial chance they would
have been maliciously destroyed which
would have been a serious serious crime
i mean that would be a serious crime
that's nixon and there's no evidence
that that happened here
it isn't but you know
how i guess what everybody's wondering
especially in light of what we went
through for three years greg
at some point when do you say the abuse
of power the corruption the the witch
hunt to quote a famous best-selling book
that this is focused on one man and one
man only and a whole double standard
exists and nobody else is ever held
accountable for either the exact law
similar sets of circumstances i know it
was different with comey but similar
the same with hillary the 33 000 emails
the dirty dossier the fisa applications
sandy berger you run through the list
and nothing ever happens if if if you're
not a conservative or republican or a
trump supporter yeah let's just take one
of those examples hillary clinton her
home in chappaqua was never rated even
though she maintained a private server
there upon which she downloaded uh
classified
top secret documents thereby
jeopardizing national security and
violating the espionage not once or ten
times but roughly a hundred times
accounting for the number of classified
documents that she essentially stole
and as i say jeopardized national
security to hacks and we in fact have
pretty solid evidence that her server
was hacked and foreign agencies
retrieved american top-secret documents
because of her actions was she ever
prosecuted no
james comey stood in front of television
cameras uh and he identified all the
crimes she committed and then did a
pirouette in the course of five seconds
and said but no reasonable prosecutor
would ever bring such a case uh
thousands of reasonable prosecutors
would have loved to have brought that
case and besides james comey isn't the
prosecuting authority he usurped the
power of the attorney general that's
just one example of the double standard
that exists with donald trump
all right
go ahead professor
i don't think you use search warrants
and prosecutions to go after political
enemies i've just written a whole book
on that called the price of principle
where i go into the whole issue of why
you don't use partisan considerations to
go after political enemies that's what
happens in banana republics that's what
happens in third world countries that's
not supposed to happen in the united
states it was right not to go after
hillary clinton because she was a
candidate for president you need a much
higher standard but you can't apply one
standard to hillary clinton and another
standard to donald trump that's
impermissible in a democracy it would
not have been a political pursuit
against hillary clinton because it
occurred during the obama administration
and the attorney general there uh she
should have been prosecuted then
all right i'm going to leave it right
there thank you
all right thank you both hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else